The square root of 98 equals 7 root 2, the square root of 150 equal 5 root 6.
And the square root of 72 equals 6 root 2. Great work if you got each of these
correct. You're really mastering your square roots. We can split up 98 into 2
times 49 and then take the square root of 49 which equals 7. The 2 states
inside of the radical are the square root. Because we can't simplify it. We use
a similar approach for the square root of 150. We rewrite 150 as 25 times 6.
And take the square root of 25 to get 5 root 6. And finally, for the square
root of 72, we rewrite 72 as 36 times 2. And then take the square root of 36.
Which leaves us with 6 times the square root of 2 or 6 root 2. I hope you're
starting to see some patterns with square roots. And, if anything, you can
always start simplifying these even numbers by dividing by 2. I've shown you
the quickest way to get to the final answers but there are, of course, some
other ways you could have gotten there as well. Be sure to compare your work to
these answers to see if you could have gotten to the answer more quickly.